colette texte de chiara art ségo et
aymeric vincenot illustrations de chiara
art ségo océan jeunesse comme elle
aimait le faire chaque matin en se
réveillant colette se blottit tendrement
dans les bras de son mari ernest je
n'avais jamais remarqué à quel point tu
veux devenez poilus en vieillissant
lurie glisse at elle en riant
ni à quel point tu es poil devenait
blanc est lui d'autres réponses qu un
ronflement satisfait une fois levée elle
s'assied devant sa coiffeuse et applique
à son masque de beauté
n'ayant pas chaussé ses lunettes elle
plie ça les yeux et se trouve à une
drôle de tête
moi non plus vieillir ne me réussit pas
plaisant at elle sans remarquer le panda
qui face à elle s'amusait à reproduire
ses moindres gestes
elle se glissa dans la baignoire en
poussant ce qu'elle croyait être son
mari airness tu sais bien qu'il n'y a
pas de place pour nous deux dans cette
baignoire
nous sommes désormais trop gros pour
nous baigner ensemble à son grand
étonnement elle eut une fois encore pas
de réponse et dû consentir à partager
son bain se sentant décidément à l'e3
elle sorti rapidement et s'assit de
nouveau devant sa glace
le panda avait disparu et elle se trouva
bien meilleure mine
elle commença à s'appliquer de la poudre
sur le visage et la caresse du pinceau
lui sembla bien plus douce que
d'habitude elle s'étonna ensuite carsac
bros semblait bouché mais elle trouve à
ce massage inattendu bien agréable une
fois prête colette s'attaqua à ses
tâches habituelles d'abord étendre le
linge se dit elle à voix haute en se
saisissant du bac sans pouvoir son chat
billy confortablement endormi au sommet
du tas de vêtements et après un pantalon
ou jupe billy se retrouve à tête en bas
suspendus au fil le linge étendu il
était temps de sortir balto le chien que
tu donc aujourd'hui balto est toi qui
tire plus fort que d'habitude sur la
lesse ou moi qui n'ai plus la force de
tenir
questionna colette pennant a su
un impressionnant reptiles qui n'était
pas balto sans voir les regards effrayés
des voisins une fois rentrés colette dû
se hisser sur la pointe des pieds pour
suspendre à bout de bras son manteau je
me tasse de plus en plus il faudra que
je demande à airness de refixer le
portemanteau un peu plus bas pense à
colette colette décider ensuite de
repeindre le salon tâche qu'elle
repoussait depuis longtemps déjà
elle s'attarde à particulièrement à un
endroit du mur
toutes ces tâches noires ce mur méritait
bien un coup de neuf
la peinture terminé il était l'heure
d'aller chercher julie sa petite fille à
l'école colette enfila son manteau qu'à
lui une fois encore du mal à décrocher
temps il était au puy pris son étal et
son sac
ce julie remarqua que la fourrure autour
du cou de sa grand-mère remuer et la
regarder d'un air amusé après son but et
julie à la dans sa chambre mais quelques
minutes minutes plus tard elle entendit
sa grand-mère qui parlait elle parle
tout seul maintenant se demanda à la
petite fille dans le salon elle vit
collègues qui malgré ses lunettes sur le
nez intimes est un étrange les arcs a
semblé confondre avec julie d'aller
faire ses devoirs
je n'ai pourtant pas une tête de lézat
rigola la fillette
mais que faisait donc cet animal dans le
salon de sa grand mère julie trop
contente de ne pas avoir à faire ses
devoirs se garda bien d'intervenir
collex assis à son bureau cherchant
désespérément la plus avec laquelle elle
aimait traditionnellement écrire sa
liste de commissions
elle pense à l'avoir retrouvée sur le
derrière d'une autruche qui passait par
là et qui lui offrit un morceau de son
plumage un peu contre son gré colette à
pelage uni pour qu elles l'accompagnent
faire ses courses elle cru la voir dans
l'entré déjà vêtu de son manteau rouge
est lui pris la main avant de sortir au
marché les commerçants étaient partagés
entre l'incrédulité et l'amusement en
voyant cette grand-mère d'habitude si
normal promener un singe mais personne
ne voulut faire de commentaire de peur
de paraître impoli auprès du
fidèle cliente en rentrant elle se
rendit à la cuisine en entendant colette
le kangourou tenta de se cacher surprise
non seulement la vieille dame ne le
voyais pas mais en plus il n'aurait plus
besoin d'aller se servir car la vieille
dame ranger ses courses dans sa poche
ventrale collègues puis enfin s'asseoir
confortablement devant la télévision
juste à l'heure pour son feuilleton
quotidien elle pestait contre la
télécommande qui refusait de fonctionner
tout en continuant d'appuyer avec
insistance sur la carapace d'une petite
tortue qui agitait les pattes pour
s'échapper
colette était encore contrarié d'avoir
raté son feuilleton quand son mari
rentre à la maison
ernest ri en voyant ses propres lunettes
sur le nez de sa femme tu ne t'es même
pas rendu compte que nous avons échangé
nos lunettes ce matin je suis parti avec
les tiennent plus explicative à cela ne
m'a pas du tout gêné lui répondit tél en
revanche la télécommande ne fonctionne
plus
j'ai raté mon feuilleton et je n'ai pas
pu voir les informations
tu ne connaît donc pas la dernière les
animaux du zoo se sont échappés la nuit
dernière
il paraît qu'ils étaient maltraités en
tout cas ils sont introuvables lui a
pris son mari eh bien ils ne sont
certainement pas ici je les aurais vu
assure un collègue en rentrant dans sa
chambre elle s'émerveille à des dizaines
des toiles brillant à travers la pièce
le lendemain colette fut réveillé par
des bruits provenant de la cuisine elle
y trouva les animaux qui préparait le
petit déjeuner ernest vient voir à plate
elle se demanda si elle n'avait pas une
fois de plus emprunter les lunettes de
son mari airness se frotta longuement
les yeux avant de se rendre à l'évidence
les animaux avaient trouvé refuge chez
eux
colette réussi à convaincre airness de
les garder son mari pourtant s'inquiéter
nous ne sommes plus tout jeune et ses
animaux vont nous donner du travail en
plus ils avaient tort les animaux
contraire leur épargner bien des tâches
la girafe était bien utile pour récurer
les coûts
hier le phoque n'avait pas son pareil
pour nettoyer le sol de la salle de
bains et grâce aux kangourous et à sa
poche
colette n'avait pu apporter son lourd
kaba quand elle faisait ses courses tous
les matins les oeufs de l'autruche
constituer un copieux petit-déjeuner et
le singe rapporté des fruits de tous les
arbres du quartier surtout colette et
ernest ne manquait jamais de compagnie
et les animaux dans leur nouveau foyer
recevait enfin l'affection qu'il n'avait
jamais eue au zoo